so what is wags wags stands for wives
and girlfriends of sports stars yeah and
I think it originated in the UK you know
Victoria Beckham and you know and my
gazelle wags
so that's where wag came from you know
it's a woman that has a lifestyle you
know you go to the games and you see
them in their little section and you
know all the wives and the girlfriends
are talking it's like that's the image
that it's supposed to be and if the
community is that it is it real it
really is because you know I feel like
you all have similar you know you're
you're all on the same boat together hmm
you all have are dating or married to a
man who is in the limelight yeah and
they play sports it's a different world
than like getting after dating a model
you know it's a sports world right so
with the sports world you're gonna get
you know I mean you get your groupies
obviously it's your like a ladder though
like the the wives are at the top the
girlfriends hierarchy thing right yeah
is that really in place whatever you
guys are all dating athletes so just
because we have it married one you guys
want to talk about us yeah I don't
really believe in the hierarchy I don't
I don't like associate with it as that
but there definitely is you do have your
wives who look down at girlfriends I
feel like me I accept everybody to like
hey we're here
it's fake its fake how did you meet
Larry I went to a friend's birthday
party he and he was there he was with
another girl what happened so you know
we got introduced and so it's just like
nice to meet you or whatever it wasn't a
girlfriend he tried to go on a date with
me for like um a whole whole month yeah
I was just so busy and I did not want to
really date I I didn't know I was like
dating an athlete like I ain't I don't
know if this is for me like I'm trying
to like really like focus on work yeah
finally give him a chance we went on a
date and we've been together ever since
[Music]
now let's talk about your wedding day
all day was it special is it everything
you wanted it was magical like I had my
mom and my dad both walking down you
know I had an orchestra playing it was
just like a fairy tale the ocean was
behind and I just like was just staring
at him you know the biggest smile on his
face it was like what's the most amazing
moment are you planning to have kids
very soon or do you are you gonna wait
for a while and we've talked about it I
definitely would be ready soon
probably a little sooner than him you
know guys are always like yeah but I
mean we have to do all the work I have
to carry the baby
you know I feed the baby like he doesn't
know to do nothing yeah I don't know why
he's like I don't know why I'm ready
before him but I would say in a couple
years we'll definitely be ready so no
real baby news yet for the couple but
Nicole does have a baby in the form of
her new swimwear collection Mia Lynn so
my mom was always a seamstress and like
always designed on my clothes when I was
growing up and like all my Halloween
costumes and so I kind of just learned
from girls like it's really hard to buy
an amazing swimsuit yeah you love that
you love that you feel it more using it
you feel sexy and it fits right yeah so
it's like why don't I just try to do
like a small swimwear collection this
started like two years ago great and so
you know I design six pieces it's a very
small collection
it's coming out like during the holidays
it's called me LM I'm really excited
about it in my baby